فقط انه معلومات جديده من الميدان
تركيز على اهم عاصمه في العالم اللي هي
عاصمتنا العظيمه الرياض يعني تاريخها
القديم الضارب في القدم الاحداث اللي مرت
عليها من ناحيه جغرافيه من ناحيه انسانيه
ومن ناحيه اثريه
هذا هو الجديد كل الحلقات ستكون في الموسم
الثامن
ركز على الرياض على تاريخ الرياض على
تاريخها من من القدم يعني نحكي عن عن مئات
السنين ولا عن الدول السعوديه الثلاث ولا
لا يعني الاف السنين الى الدوله السعوديه
الثالثه طبعا من التاسيس الدوله السعوديه
الاولى ثم الثانيه ثم الثالثه قبلها يعني
العصر الاسلامي كله وقبل الاسلام لكننا
بدانا من ما وجدناه من اثار موجوده في
الرياض تعود لعصور قديمه جدا الى العصور
الحديثه
يا دكتور
مفاتيح او عطنا يعني خلينا نقول يعني ابرز
الاشياء اللي حتكون في البرنامج
واكتشفتوها سواء كانت جديده بالرياض ايضا
في اكتشافاتك ومن خلال هذه الرحله او شيء
يعني ممكن نعلق عليه في البدايات والله هو
المواقع الاثريه لانه حنا في خطى العرب
نمشي على منهجيه ليست قصص احنا
منهج نمشي على منهج اللي هو علم الاثار
علم الانسان
علم الجغرافيا هذه منهجيه ثلاثيه اسمها
ثلاثيه المعرفه الوطنيه وكلها تؤثر ببعضها
لا يمكن الانسان
يعني يتطور ويتحرك من دون تاثير جغرافي
وهذا الجغرافيا يكون فيها اثار فنادور حول
الثلاثه اركان ذي اذا ما في اثر عن الكلام
اللي نتكلم فيه اثر ميداني شاخص لا نتكلم
عنه وبالتالي نشوف على خطى العرب ما يشوف
قصص
يعني انت ما تدعونا يستمع الى قصص فيها
على الخطوه العرب هذه القصص اسمها
الميثادولوجي لو نبي نتكلم عن قصص اقدر
اجلس على الكرسي في اي مكان يعني في
محاضره وجامعه واتكلم لكن هذه قصص ليس لها
ما يسندها من الدليل الميداني لكن عمل خطى
العرب سواء هذا الموسم الثامن عن الرياض
او المواسم السابقه هو اذا ما في شيء يؤدي
يؤيد الكلام الذي نقوله من الميدان لا
نتكلم عنه اذا في شيء يؤيد نتكلم عنه فهو
بتركيز عن الرياض تاريخه ويهم العالم
العربي
والسعوديين والخليجيين لانه هذه المنطقه
كانت وما زالت لعبت دورا عظيما على مر
الحضارات لمنطقه الرياض احنا ليس دوله
جديده ولا كما يعني يعني سنين الماضيه
يعني قيل لنا والافلام الخارجيه هذه بلاد
طلعت من الرمل وبدو ما يخالف بدو شيء
لا هي لعبت دور حضاري قديم جدا ما زالت
الى اليوم كذلك
الدكتور في كثير من جماهير على خط العرب
اتكلم مش من الناس
خاصتك يعني جماهير البرنامج يقول انت يا
دكتور تركز على مناطق معينه بذاتها او
يمكن تعيد التكرار على هالمناطق تتوسع في
تاريخها اكثر وفي مناطق اخرى اغفلتها او
ما زرتها الى الان بصراحه ما عمري كررت من
الموسم الاول والحين دخلنا الموسم الثامن
ما كررت موضوع مره اخرى نتنقل صحيح
تكرار المنطقه مش الموضوع
جغرافيه هذا اول مره نسوي عن الرياض بهذا
التوسع ان شاء الله انا فهمت سؤالك كل مدن
المملكه وقراها سنمر عليها بحول الله
تعالى من اقصى الجنوب الى اقصى الشمال
وبنقص الشرق الى الغرب الى الوسط
مدينه هذا الموسم الثامن عن الرياض ان شاء
الله الموسم الثاني ستكون عن ابها عن
الباحه عن عسير عن جيزان عن نجران عن عرعر
عن طريف عن القريات عن القصيم هذا هو يعني
نريد
والجزيره العربيه والسعوديه دوري قاره هذه
يعني احنا نواجه صعوبات كبيره يعني عطر
الخطى العربي الموسم الثامن ذا
الصعوبات اللي واجهناها لا يمكن تخيلها
يعني جبل طويق رقيناه خمس مرات مع الطرق
القديمه سترونها في الموسم هذا تابعوها
طرق الجد ودروب اخرى تاريخيه مرصوفه ترقى
الجبال نرقي الاجهزه والكاميرات
وتانى عواصف كما استمر دكتور التصوير
التصوير بدون توقف ابدا يعني لا راحه ولا
ساعه ولا سبت واحد ولا شيء 35 يوم بدون
توقف وبدون راحه لا ظهر ولا عصر ولا جمعه
حوالي 25 حلقه كامله يعني لكن ان شاء الله
بتكون شامله عن الرياض وتاريخ الرياض
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات